es gibt wohl kaum einen bereich unseres
lebens in denen man nicht auf
verschwörungstheorien kreft die
mondlandung hat nie stattgefunden krebs
ist nicht heilbar oder flüchtlinge sind
alle verbrecher das ist natürlich unsinn
und wir fragten wieder weg und doch wie
schaut es mit den verschwörungstheorien
so wie nie und sie sind gefährlich also
wie erkennt man verschwörungstheorien
was haben die illuminaten damit zu tun
und warum gibt es sie überhaupt jede
sieben wichtigsten fakten jetzt weg zum
zweiten fiction herzlich willkommen fakt
ein verschwörungs theorien gibt es schon
ewig damit eine richtig gute
verschwörungstheorie überhaupt entstehen
kann muss ihr inhalt verbreitet werden
die grundlage dafür lieferte wohl die
erfindung der druckpresse um 1450 herum
seitdem konnten bücher in hohen auflagen
gedruckt werden
zudem gab es immer mehr leute die lesen
konnten während der aufklärung lieferten
verschwörungstheorien dann den ersatz
für den glauben viele leute wandten sich
in dieser zeit von der religion ab und
nicht mehr nur gott wurde seitdem
verantwortlich gemacht dafür was in der
welt so passiert allerdings gibt es auch
andere experten und expertinnen die sich
mit verschwörungstheorien auseinander
gesetzen und der meinung sind dass es
wie so lange gibt wie die menschen es
erklären wir mit der evolution dass wir
menschen evolutionsbedingt vorsichtig
sein mussten um zu überleben forderte
demnach die bildung von
verschwörungstheorien für die menschen
weiß nämlich seit anbeginn sinnvoll
gewesen sich in gruppen zusammen zu tun
und sich anderen menschen gegenüber
misstrauisch zu zeigen weiter fakt
verschwörungstheorien sind gefährlich
für alle eine australische studie legt
nahe dass anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien dazu neigen
etablierte wissenschaftliche fakten
abzulehnen
beispielsweise halten wie das rauchen
für unschädlich um mit sie sich am ende
natürlich erst einmal weg schreiben aber
verschwörungstheorien können nicht nur
dazu führen dass menschen sich selbst
schaden vor allem bei theorien die
bestimmte gruppen von menschen schlecht
machen besteht das risiko dass diese
gruppen auch körperlich angegriffen
werden einige forscher und forscherinnen
sehen aber auch vorteile in
verschwörungstheorien durch die skepsis
können auch positives bewirkt werden
falls die theorien auf echte probleme
hinweisen wenn auch durch argumente die
nicht der wahrheit entsprechen bus
erfasst verschwörungstheorien stiften
vermeintlich sind verschwörungstheorien
sind so erfolgreich weil sie den leuten
angebote liefern dinge zu erklären und
dabei sinn stiften allerdings so
vermeintlich psychologisch gesehen
bekommen ihre anhänger so also ein
exklusives wissen wodurch die gefahr
abwenden können und sich in sicherheit
wiegen ereignisse die in keinem
zusammenhang stehen finden den
verschwörungstheorien plötzlich
zueinander
doch gleichzeitig machen sie auch angst
doch was macht eine verschwörungstheorie
zu einer waschechten
verschwörungstheorie die sind sich
experten nicht ganz einig einige
definieren drei komponenten aus denen
die verschwörungstheorie steht erstens
ein plan der verfolgt wird zweitens eine
gruppe die ihn ausgeheckt hat und ihn
angeblich verfolgt und brücken zu dem
der charakter des geheimen gut und böse
juli ihren sich diejenigen die
verschwörungstheorien in die welt setzen
haben dieser definition nach nichts
gutes im sinn
ein weiteres wichtiges kriterium ist
anderen experten zufolge die vermeidung
der wahrheit die verschwörungstheorien
wie er spricht also eine offiziell
anerkannte version eines ereignisses
oder vorgang förder fakt
verschwörungstheorien sind heutzutage
sichtbarer als früher
durch das internet bekommt die
verwaltung von verschwörungstheorien
natürlich noch einmal eine ganz neue
dimension
das ist nicht verwunderlich die
verbreitung aber auch die vernetzung mit
anderen anhängern ist sehr viel
einfacher geworden allerdings gibt es
keine studien die belegen dass heute
tatsächlich mehr menschen als früher an
den glauben seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
werden verschwörungstheorien in europa
immer weniger ernst genommen
ganz im gegensatz zu der arabischen welt
und osteuropa beispielsweise dort gelten
wie für viele menschen als glaubhafter
und wind stiftender als medien wie große
fernsehsender oderzeitung fünfter fakt
anhänger von verschwörungstheorien gibt
es in allen sozialen schichten zudem
hinweise darauf dass vor allem junge und
er ungebildete menschen an
verschwörungstheorien glauben doch
anhänger wind wohl in allen sozialen
schichten zu finden
mehr aber noch bei menschen die sehr
religiös sind oft sind diejenigen fans
von verschwörungstheorien die ihre
eigene identität in gefahr sehen wie
zwei wenn männer über
vier jahren die laut studien häufig
verschwörungstheorien im netz
kommentieren viele von ihnen haben wohl
angst vor den konsequenzen der
emanzipation und globalisierung so der
erklärungsversuch der forscherinnen und
forscher festhalten kann man wohl dass
all diejenigen die sich in eine extreme
richtung bewegen weiß nur politisch oder
religiös anfällig sind für
verschwörungstheorien
denn viele von ihnen fühlen sich wohl
als außenseiter verschwörungen können
dann laut forschung herhalten um für
diesen zustand eine vermeintliche
erklärung zur fifa sechster fakt die
erste bekannte verschwörungstheorie ist
wo die über die illuminaten der jury
nach unserer heutigen definition ging wo
zu zeiten der französischen revolution
durch die welt gesteuert wo sind demnach
die revolution vom geheimbund der
illuminaten dieser bund existierte
allerdings schon damals nicht mehr
allerdings würde auch heute noch mit
einer weltverschwörung in zusammenhang
gebracht für die es aber keinerlei
beweise
sie packt die gegenargumente lassen an
herrn noch mehr daran glaubt wie geht
man am besten mit anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien jetzt fehlt es an
eindeutigen studien anhänger von
verschwörungstheorien sind aber wohl
noch am ehesten anfänglich für fakten
empfänglich sobald sie dann vollends
überzeugt sind kann es passieren dass
wir durch starke gegner haben die
argumente noch mehr an ihre theorie
glauben und damit also das gegenteil
erreicht wird bei impfgegner zum
beispiel gelten von ärzten vorgebrachte
argumente als beweis ihrer
verschwörungstheorie weil sie ja besagt
dass ärzte die pharmaindustrie
unterstützen und deshalb für das impfen
werden dann sind dann wirklich hopfen
und malz verloren wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollen wenn ich mal wieder
eine abstruse verschwörungstheorie
auseinander nehmen dann wird mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit
evolutionstheorie endgültig bestätigt er
touristen auf verlorenem posten
da geht es um die kreationisten die ohne
jeden preis meinen dass gott gewesen
hier auf der erde erschaffen hat warum
das totaler blödsinn ist und die
evolutionstheorie im gegensatz bewiesen
dass erfahrt ihr wenn ihr auf das video
clip von ansonsten bis dann bleib dran